bien un bonjour bonjour jean baptiste
bonjour stéphane on va voir aujourd'hui
une ouverture typique moderne en fait
c'est une nature qui s'est développée au
20e chine 3ème siècle mais voilà c'est
une ouverture qu'on appelle la défense
peer to peer
si on est un puriste du mot de la langue
du mot slave en tout cas puisque cette
ouverture a été développé par par les
fameux tacticien yougoslave une
ouverture à priori d'attac avec les
noirs mais extrêmement risqué voilà
alors on a choisi ça c'est donc c'est
donc par rapport à d'autres ouvertures
comme la carro cannes par exemple où la
petrov qui sont une autre plutôt calmes
où les noirs essayé de tenir une
position relativement facile à tenir sur
le long terme les plans racines pouvoir
compte du mercure dynamique plan du est
la différence entre la carro cannes où
la petrov ou que 4,5 n'importe quelle
ouverture avec 4,5 avec la pire qui est
bien c'est la pire que est une ouverture
qui laisse le centre ou blanc donc ça
crée un déséquilibre pour un jeu sur les
ailes
c'est ça la différence il ya deux
familles d'ouverture les ouvertures qui
se battent pour le centre et celles qui
ne se battent pas pour le stand pour
obtenir du jeu sur les ailes
donc si on a un jeu dynamique où on aime
bien la coulée puissions complexe on
choisira plutôt la pire qu'avec les
noirs
ouais voilà ça amène des positions
déséquilibré est un peu un peu folle
alors on va voir ça qu'est ce que c'est
que cette défense pirc qui pose des
problèmes alors on a une partie ici
qu'ils nous servent fil conducteur qui
lie la partie à nantes contre channing
crowder nine qui était un bon joueur de
pire qu il faut savoir que depuis cette
période là on a rarement joué là la pire
canon au près comme en entrée de voir
que ça donne pas envie traite la pierre
oui mais bon on a un côté vie en vue de
son 8e position si on me la jouer on
peut quand même à jouer on va voir qu'il
ya quand même du ressort pour lui non
bien sûr c'est une position qui est
extrêmement compliqué mais disons que
contrat demande alors nous on n'est pas
dans des mesures contraignantes
on s'y laisse que plus alors elle a
contraint nombre pour l'instant les on
s'y risquent plus mais on va voir ça
l'ordre de 4,4 à l'arrêt la drisse
ensuite que veulent faire les noirs ils
veulent sortir le cavalier ans m6 et
adopter un funk et au roi ils veulent
jouer le g6 on connait cette formation
c'est une formation dite destin vienne
moyens destinés ou à même le dragon un
dragon est indien le funk et le roi qui
donne une une vie au pouget 7
voilà le fou va occuper la plus grande
diagonale possible sur l'échiquier et
donc on va obtenir beaucoup de gens que
ça se fout alors si on veut sortir les
pièces cavalia si j'ai six coups g7 le
cavaliere m6 on peut pas le savoir tout
de suite il faut lui assurer une
stabilité
oui parce que sinon de 4,5 et on est
dans une ère de 85 c'est autre chose
dans une allée keane et à assurer la
stabilité
eh bien on peut jouer t6 la stabilité
pourquoi parce que maintenant comme
cavalier va sortir en rêve 6 et bien le
coup eux 4 5 ne sera pas possible
puisque la classe des contrôlés par le
plan dessiné sur donc on y va des quatre
cavaliers 6 donc là l'idée tout de suite
et puis ça attaque
évidemment le pion tu as donc il faut
protéger en développant une pièce est le
mieux les risques naturels cavaliers ses
droits
l'idée générale donc que tu viens de
citer delapierre qu donc de jouer le
fils keto avec ce coup j'ai cette
justice qui prépare le four g7 avec une
très belle diagonale i qui l'idée
principale fouet trois la part des
blancs donc ça c'est précis comme coûts
déjà alors c'est un coup extrêmement
précis c'est le bon ordre
donc on voit clairement les intentions
des blancs ici regardez-le elle qu'ils
ont développé en premier un bain c1 il
ya plus de pièces les pièces ont été
développés on veut faire le grand roque
quand on veut attaquer à 100 kg et au il
ya une manière d'attaquer très classique
et très connu qui s'appelle l' attaque à
la baïonnette
alors on joue avec fougue 3 et d'amd 2
mais la dame en batterie avec le fou
pour pouvoir emmener ce fou sur la chine
pour qu'ils s'échangent contre le fu g7
qui rappelons le principal défenseur du
rock
en plus d'être une pièce d'attac cette
pièce d'une pièce très forte c'est pour
ça que les blancs cherche à les changer
d'autre part une fois que cet
affaiblissement sera fait après les
changes
on veut essayer de jouer h4h anc pour
ouvrir la colonne h est ainsi valorisé
la tour qui n'a pas eu besoin d'être
amis en f1 après un roc
on a fait le grand roque et on imagine
après facilement une combinaison tour et
dames sur la colonne h approche la dame
est allée sur la case noire et à l'appui
envahir voilà nous fait des faits des
belles peintures et comme ça on comprend
bien
on comprend bien le chemin des pièces h
4 h 5
on échange et après on va enrichissent
pour une attaque très virulente sur le
petit rock
ce qui rappelle aussi le dragon le
dragon ce qu'on appelle l'ouverture
dragon de la sicilienne c'est pas la
sicilienne c'est la pire tu sais pas
peut-être une ouverture ne parlera la
variance amish de l'est indienne aussi
que ces voix là en fait trouvé que des
familles d'ouverture on commence pas
forcément par le premier coup toujours
le même mais en tout cas les perles sont
typiques ce sont les mêmes voile avant
les mêmes s'affrontent fouet 3 et la c6
alors ses six ans et si ça c'est le coup
le coup le plus précis en fait à noter
qu'on craint pas vraiment à la place de
ces siffle coup cavaliers g4 on va le
voir si les noirs jouent clavier g4 qui
attaquent le fou hein qui attaquent le
fou alors évidemment on le laisse pas se
fout hein ce front veux pas qu'ils
échangent contre les cavaliers il y aura
laissé le fou noir des noirs tout seul
pour contrôler les 15 mois est tout seul
pour tenir tout le centre eh bien on
pourrait peut-être tout simplement jouer
fou g5 ou faut être quatre c'est une
possibilité
il est ensuite chassé le cavalier avec l
3 mai sur 11 jours et f3 qui consolide
le pion aux quatre ensuite on pourra
quand même joué dans me2 et faire la
science dont rien à la position dans ce
procès que ce coup on ne craint pas du
tout bien sûr
voilà un coup qui fait peur au premier
abord mais qui n'est pas avoir privé a
priori les français par exemple sur fou
j'ai 5 / h 6 dans ce cas l'on joué en 4
ou iphone os 4 mai mais la halle et noir
ont affaibli les gones se sont
affaiblies et on va on va avoir des
cibles encore plus ça sera dur à des
percées beaucoup plus facile à une
séance et après après un coup contre x
le 4e prix f3 on peut ramener le fou en
f2 ce qui est classique aussi et on voit
même le revenir 3 si on alimente
seulement voilà donc pas de problème
avec ça alors par contre si les noirs ne
joue pas le coût 6,6 et fils c'est un
coup
c'est un coup mal en est
on l'a rappelé un de qufu g7 avec l'idée
de roque et vite se serait carrément
rock et côté cimetière alors on va le
voir on va le voir tout de suite s'il
est noir voilà le développement du ray
logique par rapport au premier coup ça
serait passif alors on continue le
développement logique pour les blancs
c'est un exemple au monde dames des deux
mains des deux est sûre petit rock bien
on peut déjà commencer à envisager grand
kiff ohashi sauf au hcc grand raout
soi-même fois-ci s'enrichissent et là on
comprend l'idée avec la menace simple h
4 h 5
voilà une cerise angers7 une prise
angers 6 est d'un machisme qui arrive
après on prend et ensuite la dame vient
ici on déloge ce cavalier parfois par
des sacrifices et après on mate
alors c'est un petit peu direct mais ça
marche pas mal ça marche par contre la
différence avec donc ça c'est à
déconseiller évidemment le côté noir
c'est facile à travailler du côté blanc
il attaque et immédiates on va faire
l'idée principale de l'ouverture c'est
l'idée principale alors par contre les
noirs jouent le coup beaucoup plus
précis et subtile qui essaient 6 voilà
c'est 6 par contre parce que là l'idée
des noirs avec le coup c'est 6 c'est bon
d'avoir rien qui contrôle central ici
sur la place des seins voilà mais c'est
là que pour vous c'est là qu'on comprend
que l'âge le jeu de la pire qui
s'étagent sur les ailes bien sûr le sait
si c'est évidemment pour préparer la
poussée b5 qui est un peu une sorte une
sorte de chantage pour les blancs merci
d'accord j'ai vu ton plein fouet trois
dames des deux gros rock
vas-y rock de ce côté là et moi je suis
capable d'attaquer aussi sur l'ale je
suis prêt à dégainer b5 des 4b quatre
attaques lecavalier 3 et le pion de
quatre tombes
déjà père la défense du pion et sans
compter que si on a fait grand roque
évidemment ce sont des pions très très
menaçants pour aller la fabrique
attaquer laurent rock de leur côté aussi
donc extrêmement agressif ou c6 qui n'a
l'air de rien prépare en fait une grosse
avancé des pions du côté d'ing voilà
donc que font les noirs et les blancs là
dessus eh bien il joue un coup mal un
petit coup malin alors ils vont quand
même continué leurs plans voilà pas
s'arrêter mais ils ne vont pas troquer
trop vite ils vont quand même avoir ce
petit jeu d'observation qui se retrouve
très souvent dans les ouvertures où on
joue des coûts utile tout en observant
quand même les réponses de l'adversaire
bien sûr parce que si si d'aventuré les
noirs attaque trop vite avant que j'aie
route et si genre de l'autre côté ça
devient n'affaiblisse
oui c'est bien une mauvaise surprise
pour tant qu'on n'a pas donné l'adresse
du roi faut pas non plus trop dévoiler
son jeu voilà en gros c'est ça c'est le
premier en fait le premier qui choisit
où il veut aller qui l'avait de nodrest
qui va avoir quelques soucis
voilà c'est exact faut pas donner sur la
base mais oui le but du jeu étant de
chasser le roi cinéma vous dis tout de
suite ou vague où va votre or forcément
ça complique la tâche
bien sûr est roi alors f3 voilà dont ses
consolide ici au solide 4 donc ça tient
compte de la menace b5 bi 4 et puis on
se soutient aussi le plonger qui
pourrait aller de g2j quatre pour aider
le pion h4 allez y en a chaque voilà
voilà un peu l'idée de cesse de secouer
f3 donc b5 b5
voilà donc là on voit que donc l'endroit
déjà que la menace bk tout de suite pour
4 est inopérante à cause de ce coup et
trois vols intérieurs sur la bien aimée
voilà donc l'intérêt de ce coup très
fort donc là et donc c'est sans
compromis tout de suite pour les blancs
puisque c'est quand même g4g quatre
heures avec ici donc début d'une attaque
ici deux pions g4 qui a un come back est
aussi un coup centrale parce que j'ai 4
sa menace au moment opportun peut-être
un g5 qui va chasser le cavalier f6 de
sa position centrale
alors si on peut le jouer
en ayant peut-être un gain matériel à la
clé se coucher 4 est vraiment très
intéressés bien sûr sur l'âge et 4 c'est
un coup déstabiliser le cavalier de 6
tout à fait donc là les noirs peuvent
jouer soit le coût h6 par exemple ou
alors voilà là après il ya deux ya deux
façons de jouer soit on joue à dschang
tout de suite soit le poste 5
voilà soit le coup elle voilà de quoi
chant tout de suite alors courage 5
donc là on est obligé de prendre une
décision il faut pousser les pions on
est là c'est le cavalier s'en va et
maintenant on change notre fusil d
épaule
donc il ya ici comme les 11-17 la paire
ch qu'attachante n'est plus possible on
changerait fait des pôles stephen et on
joue maintenant le coût f4 et oui parce
que là avec cette structure évidemment
h4 est inopérant par contre le coût f4
oui et on veut percer ici en f5
on peut toujours percée de l'autre côté
on connaît toujours un moyen ça qu'on
revient dans c'est que même quand les
noirs défendre précisément on peut
toujours trouver un endroit de rupture
pour les pions ou les colonnes vont
s'ouvrir ya toujours une petite
perspective comme ça il faut pas traîner
avec les blancs parce que si on l'est
ruine au mans les noirs jouer leurs
plans celles qui vont avoir une forte
attaque avec ce froid et c'est très
puissant
ah vous voyez dans cette partie a
beaucoup de pions c'est un peu contraire
aux principes généraux seront les
ouvertures bien sûr mais en fait les
deux camps cherche d'abord à prendre
leurs positions et les pions et croyez
bien que retient des deux camps n'a
oublié qu'il faille concerts des pièces
un même tout le monde est prêt à
dégainer cavaliers f3 fou détroit où
j'ai deux petits roms tout est prêt à
partir bien sûr mais dans un premier
temps les bleus ont d'abord cherché à à
prendre leurs marques donc f3b 5e g4
non non on va plutôt regarder des
variantes à chis h6 voilà dire
plus ou moins empêche le coup j'ai
simple donc dam des deux normales
continuer le développement qu'on l'avait
évidemment on tape un tout petit peu sur
six qui va retarder d'autant le pire
aucun rôle pour l'instant ça va c'est
protégé par le fouet fuite et la torah
cheville mais dès que vida mandéka petit
rock ça saute donc ça retarde le petit
rock et en plus ça peut préparer
éventuellement le grand roque qui pour
l'instant quand même et sous la menace
d'un gros d'un groupe b4 ici un peu
pénible donc il faut faire quand même
attention donc au g7 pour les noirs qui
prépare quand même du rock et surtout
qui placent leur fou sur la bande de
gaza ouais donc on est toujours dans le
classique en cette ouverture pire hélas
les plans les blancs continuent
voilà sans donner l'adresse de leurs
droits toujours voilà il applique le
plan et sandrine reste du roi h4 donc en
fait en gros il ya une sorte de poker
menteur s'ils rejettent à calais le roi
mais c'est vrai que j'aime les noirs
n'ont pas encore aucun endroit
oui et j'évite de roque et moi même
du côté dames du grand de côté puisque
je suis aussi sur la menace d'une
attaque donc il ya une attaque des noirs
sur les dames et des blancs sur les
droits alors que les auxerrois n'ont pas
décidé de savoir voilà où il faudrait ce
supposé les havrais supposé alors là il
ya deux ans où il y ait deux coups
possibles
il ya une autre partie d'un an du coach
harding d'ailleurs avec continuer par
ashoka ce moment là c'est un peu bizarre
parce qu'on a tout d'un premier coup
tant h 6 h et après on joue à quatre
changé entre-temps en à jouer ce coup là
ce coup là et à quoi il sert ce coup là
eh bien on sait déjà que ce puits en
page 4 il ne sera pas en h2 et donc
c'est important si les blancs font un
petit rock parce que savoir fait une
protection en moins pour le roi aussi
oui voilà donc c'est un petit détail qui
a son importance quand même qu'une fois
que le courage 4 a été jouée à l'ariane
et noir sont d'accord pour jouer pour
jouer à 5
d'accord elle s'offre une toute petite
différence comme une petite différence
mais bon c'est quand même un stade à
décines subtilité dans m ouais on est
donc là j'ai cinq cavaliers fdcl et 17
et si la même idée on va jouer avec f4
f5
voilà donc là on peut sortir les pièces
cavaliers ou deux cavaliers de noir
c'est une partie qui ressemble un petit
peu fou fou décès faisait sept cavaliers
g3 on replace le cavalier sur une
position et on va essayer d'arriver
stéphane plus vite possible à la
position qui nous intéresse puisque le
développement est normal est fait perdre
4 mai car on attaque le cavalier ok donc
on bouge le cavalier qui va se recycler
plus tard sur f2 on va venir avec 2
pourquoi pas ce qu'on veut sur protéger
le pion aux quatre voix la présidente en
ramène les cavaliers vers l'endroit où
on veut essayer de le mater droit bien
sûr donc qu'à aider à ses 5
donc c'est sa réaction au sens bien sûr
là en bouche voilà on essaye de faire du
sang or n'allons nous attaquer sur une
aile referme le centre bien sûr à noter
que le câble et des uns ici protège très
bien le pion b2 quand même au passage
est aussi une des raisons de venir ici
il y avait le diable et saisissent et là
on bouche encore ces quatre avec ses 4
on veut boucher absolument les
opportunités alors ça oblige la prise en
passant cavaliers prend cette énorme
talent pour reprendre du cavalier donc
on a on a relu béret sur une autre
cavalier qui était qui était passif en
bien et là les noirs ont choisi de jouer
le coup x 6 donc c'est un développement
possible d'attac ou et peuvent pour
trouver une solution pour le cavalier b
vite aussi voilà ce qu'il faut que ce
cavalier arrive à sortir pour l'instant
une aveo n'est pas mécontent d'échangés
se [ __ ] case blanche qui aurait pu
être toutes les attaques très forte
quand même le food et kahlaoui de blanc
nez blanc n'est que l'infime blanche
donc fou prend 1,6 voilà vous prend à
six cavaliers prend 1,6 on va je m'aide
à me 2002 c'est là on en vient on en
vient aux thèmes les brûlant voilà voilà
car c'est que cette façon d'attaquer
même que notre adversaire a joué à cinq
elle est très connue alors là on a deux
options ses fans pour attaquer soit on
joue vrai qu'on a des pions livres 2,4
et f4 ailleurs peut-être les deux coups
suivants ces dames civile s'est vite et
l'a5
oui mais là on avait peut-être une autre
option il est aussi intéressante c'est
intéressant aussi sur une rue 5e 5
sacrifices en fait ce sacrifice pour le
faire classique en cas de prise voilà
vingt-cinq voilà eh bien on voudrait
jouer f5 f5
à quoi a servi ce coup eu 5 a vendu f5
c'est qu'on a attiré un plongeoir sur la
case de 5 pour qu'aucune pièce ne
viennent occuper et on a libéré notre
caisse de 4 cette pièce été prise par un
pion maintenant et on va pouvoir voir
sur une très belle quasi six ans le cas
l'on voit que les cavaliers ont leur
utilité dans le calice et noir prennent
au f5 c'est le clanche seins qui tombent
voilà donc maintenant on a quand même
beaucoup de pièces en attaque pour
donc ça c'est classique aussi sinon
l'autre idée car les vols directs c'est
de jouer vous saviez bien aussi c'est f5
avec l'idée avec l'idée de venir
sacrifié en un cavalier prochain je vais
prendre à chaque dame prochain voilà
avec une menace peut-être f6 où j'ai
celle ci soit après j'ai six essais
m'attend achètent par exemple imaginons
que les blancs les noirs jouent des
coups je dirais on va dire tourbe évite
par exemple d'attentes beaucoup comme
tourbe et 8 pour attaquer sur la colombe
et on peut essayer cavaler prendre puis
on prend dans prend avec id g6 et matt
simplement bien le coup et f6 aussi le
coup m6 bien sûr je comprends que l'on
prend une foule peut pas reprendre si on
a tout revient et c'est un massacre
ouais ça serait un massacre en asie
c'est très fort aussi des bonnes
perspectives d' attaque c'est pas c'est
pas gagné mais en tout cas cessé le
thème un peut-être qu'on peut faire
l'europe d'abord on s'avoue de moduler
mais en tout cas c'est celle idées
d'attac clé de ce système voilà donc
faut connaître ce tag cachin voilà
fauconnet ce thème est pas hésité à
sacrifier avec les blancs le moment
devenu évident là on a montré de la
roque d'abord un peut-être faire leur
travail en faut peut-être évoqué un coût
et il peut être bien sûr il faut il faut
bien réfléchir à la question
voilà donc ça c'était c'est la
possibilité si les noirs jouent cette
variante avec adam un jour à 5
on revient sur la position initiale
voilà c'était sur cet avantage 5 ont
bien de voir l'idée générale qui est
donc d'harmoniser son attaque en jouant
club de calais g3 et plus tarder à me2
voilà déjà à savoir de vision il faut
savoir que le coup à chaque est un conte
qui revient tout le temps un d'ailleurs
dans d'autres
d'autres partis
de référence maintenant le coup à chaque
gène est joué sauf que qu'est ce qui a
été un terreau qu'allez-vous bessette
fou j'ai deux donc c'est vraiment une
petite nuance c'est petit mais on va
vous montrer
il n'y a pas le choix parce que sinon on
peut par ok on sait pas trop quoi faire
on sait pas trop quoi faire
ça va être difficile quoi donc achat h5
jessains alors on va regarder une partie
vraiment au similaire la voir comme ça
on aura plein de l'arrivée pour pouvoir
jouer cette variante d'attac qu'elle et
17 alors qu'elle valait h3c intéressant
on peut on peut remettre le cavalier en
rêvent de voir rihanna sur b4 quatre
attaques le kabyle c'est rare cette fois
ci on vous pas qu'il y ait des impasses
que la case f2 est pour ainsi dire
promis j'arrête cavalia je crois donc on
peut jouer cavalier de cavaliers sur ben
parce que déjà on voulait envisager de
venir ici mais l'annoncé l'autre
cavaliers qui va et qui va y aller voilà
donc la c5 un petit rôle et maintenant
un petit recueil on va sauter sur le pur
wef avec la tour donc on sait que notre
plan d'attaqué maintenant qu'un chien
qui jouissent et f4 f5 toujours pareil
f4 f5 attaqué g6 et aussi envisager
peut-être des câbles ige 3d am2 et
pourquoi pas sacrifier en jeu 5 aussi
alors voilà des thèmes bien sûr qu'elle
et ses 6 et la d5 évidemment bouche
alors on profite du cabba et 6,6 pour
attaquer en même temps qu'on bouche 7
alors l'ouverture est pour ainsi dire
terminée voilà voilà donc on a quand
même des bases assez intéressante pour
cette prochaine partie mais je crois que
ça va être très instructif tu es fan de
regarder la suite après cavaliers cs
saint-louis pour voir les plans
impossible alors ils là ils en profitent
pour jouer pour jouer et b3 qui paraît
un petit peu osé parce qu on ouvre toute
la diagonale du fou g7
oui non on va sortir s'est tourné ce
tour n'est pas destiné à rester ici donc
on profite du passage du cavalier ou 5
pour pouvoir pour choisir une b3 et
enlever 2 2
de la ligne devient tout à fait à 5 nos
fans qui arrivent et trois qu'on arrive
voilà on arrive toujours pareil à 4 donc
la torah c'est un an il était grand
temps dans mon avance non mais surtout
au pis on protège ses deux parce que
tout cas on imagine cette dame va partir
et on ne veut pas compris la colonne va
s'ouvrir donc il faut commencer à
prendre quelques petits disposition
également apprend apprend et tour à deux
voix là on voit tout de suite l'intérêt
de cette course est un évidemment
surtout rade on protège alors maintenant
on veut jouer f4 mais on veut pas
laisser la caisse j'ai quatre cavaliers
évident parce que le cavalier sur f4
viendrait sur cette caste g4 et on ne
pourrait plus où la meuse pour attaquer
h5 escaliers en plus menacé le fou et 3
serait très puissant et donc il faut
empêcher sky-g cas d'où l'idée de jouer
le simple cavaliers f2 puisque le
cavalier mais n'en ai deux protège la
cage et 4 donc en cas de qualification
fait simplement cavaliers prend
cavaliers donc la dame à saint vous avez
vu que amanda leigh des fermes
d'attaquer mais ces deux textes
construite un vraiment à régler sur le
coup de préparation qui sont très
efficaces dans le temps et puis apple
choix maintenant pour les mois et non
plus le choix en fait de la case
puisqu'après f4 ya plus de casse pour
qu'amélie tous les registres
ici il est pris ici il est pris d'un il
est pris là ici évidemment il ya le fou
heureusement parce que sinon
fourchette d agréables et là on s'est
protégé partout en chine mais il ya le
cavalier h2 donc après cavaillé g4 on
prend évidemment ce cavalier et après je
prends g4 et bien ce pion quand même un
tout petit peu faible de façon oui oui
encore un inconvénient est oui alors là
je prends le cas maintenant comment ce
qu'on peut attaquer bon on a eu un jour
l'idée vous voyez parce que si on joue
de production le coup f5
le problème c'est que ça laisse quand
même une grosse quinzaine f5 ça laisse
une grosse kazan le siège place voilà
maintenant que cette variante a été
jouée mais qualifie 4 comme ça il a mené
un pion faible angers 4 donc on a espoir
de récupérer ce pion aux gens qu'on peut
investir
on l'a pris à investir un pion parce que
ça va quand même libéré beaucoup de
pièces avec l'idée toujours pareil que
si les noirs prennent évidemment joué 5
bah oui et on vient sur la case 4 et on
ya un embouteillage et les pièces noires
qui n'arrive pas à jouer parce que le
plus simple est jeune bien sûr la
pression c'est cette thématique
également dans une ouverture que qu'il
avait omis par exemple rendez vite
trois des huit alors là il s'en va parce
que ça commençait à chauffer il a
maintenant eu 6 voilà qui casse la
structure noir puisque le pion f7 va
être échangé dans du coup le pion g6
aussi va être faibles qui ont g4 est
déjà faible
donc on est déjà dans une partie bien
avancé l'argent qu'on peut
c'est on peut laisser tomber pour pour
la suite de la partie 1 là vous pourrez
l'as rome regardez peut-être dans votre
base en tout cas c'est une partie qu'on
a qu'on a choisi puisque le plan est
simple on peut peut-être reprendre au
début bien sûr on va reprendre les
premiers coups au début avec cette
benoni ici sur fouet trois avec cette
grande idée de jouer dan des deux fois
ci ce qui est commune à d'autres
variantes comme le dragon et ses défauts
et 3 et d'amd de on met faux et dames en
batterie pour attaquer les cinq étaient
jusque là c est classique et là où est
alors les l'autre l'autre grand thème d'
attaque c'est de jouer
par contre sur le pion à l'or s'est
trouvé voilà sur h5 voilà quand les
noirs a rejoint la structure avec hcl ne
pas hésiter avec les blancs de jouer le
coup j'ai 5
oui toute façon il attaque est cependant
qu'il faut se voit la façon d'accommoder
avec qui des pôles tarde de jouer f4
avec dame 2 et un cavalier qui vient de
ranger trois attaques et carrément h5
pour faire une menace de sacrifices
voilà est couplé avec une impossibilité
d'attac aussi au centre soit avec f5
soit avec eux cinq comme on vient de le
voir beaucoup de possibilités pour
ouvrir des colonnes voilà en tout cas
celle attaque à tout va c'est vraiment
une attaque c'est vraiment une ouverture
et noir provoque les blancs depuis ce
qui leur laisse le centre les laisse
venir et vont jouer très tactique et à
tout moment aussi prendre le dessus
il ya la forme des pions c'est un jeu de
flandre si ça vous voyez on tue dix ans
un jeu de flan de flanc à une flandre
attaques de flambée des attaques de
flanc pour une attaque non pas central
mais fait du côté rail d'un côté oui
c'est ça exactement c'est une sorte
d'encerclement les noirs ici d'encercler
le centre et demi voilà
et les blancs doivent profiter de leur
centre pour essayer de jouer sur les
côtés pour faire reculer les appuis du
centre blanc après pour pouvoir mieux
l'attaquer l'idée c'est d'attaquer sur
le rock aussi pour les noirs un résumé
des blancs voiliers ont quand même pas
mal d'arguments leur disposition pour
voilà est à noter de ne pas hésiter dans
cette ouverture là aussi donc de ne pas
donner l'adresse dure entre tous
ah oui c'est quelque chose qui a dit
vous étonner c'est qu'on a rocket
retraite alors c'est quoi cette
ouverture qui vont nous faire jouer avec
ce roi qui restent au centre tout le
temps c'est vrai vous avez raison de le
penser si vous y avez pensé
gardez toujours cette possibilité de
rockets ne fait pas forcément trop tôt
quand il l'a dit n'est pas l'adresse
mais soyez un coup du rock
ça c'est un concert qu'on peut vous
donner ma démission un coup dur pour
pouvoir partir c'est con ça va ça
commence vraiment à surfer ou pas c'est
important si vous ne riez pas rester
quand même seulement un coup dur
inconnus qui ne traînez pas trop quand
même
et puis alors et puis alors évidemment
garder les deux options drogue c'est
l'idéal puisque on peut changer deux
options de côté quand on veut voilà donc
très intéressant c'est de cette pierre
donc complexe une ouverture au monde est
complexe il faut quand même bien
maîtriser un des deux côtés c'est cette
attaque à la baïonnette
voilà qui est vraiment plaisante à jouer
exactement risqué mais bon c'est un peu
pour ça qu'on joue aux échecs aussi d'un
exactement sur plaisir là on a des
variantes facile et plaisante facile et
plaisante facile à comprendre avec merci
jean baptiste pour cette leçon sur la
pire la ciguatera stéphane mettons très
bientôt